cómo
vamos
[Aplausos]
hola buenas tardes a todos es un gusto
para mí estar aquí soy jose castilla y
permítanme comenzar contándoles una
historia
esa persona que ustedes ven volando ahí
es mariana es mi hermana entre mariana y
yo hay 8 años de diferencia y junto con
mis padres conformamos una familia de
cuatro integrantes mariana ha inyectado
a nuestra familia emoción es una persona
con muchos objetivos y pronto empezará
la universidad pero es uno de los
motivos por los cuales yo estoy aquí
parado
marian a mi hermana es fruto de una
técnica de reproducción asistida
pudiera sorprendernos que una de cada
seis parejas que busca un embarazo logra
concebir pensando que la primera
fecundación in-vitro se realizó en 1978
actualmente las causas de infertilidad
se dividen en 40% para hombres 40 por
ciento para mujeres y un 20% de causas
desconocidas cuando pensamos en la gente
que nos importa en nuestra gente con la
que elaboramos en nuestros amigos de
nuestra pareja e incluso nuestras
familias cuando alguien tiene un
problema lo natural es querer ayudar y
buscamos una solución basada en nuestra
experiencia personal y creemos que una
solución fácil puede ser apta para una
realidad muchísimo más compleja estas
personas que viven problemas de
infertilidad comparten muchos
sentimientos que invaden todas las
esferas por las que pasan en su vida es
una persona que al hacer las actividades
más cotidianas como ir al supermercado o
entrar a un parque encuentra la nueva
noticia de pañales para bebés y las
nuevas técnicas de lactancia materna que
en su celular de whatsapp una amiga que
ni siquiera estaba buscando un embarazo
logró concebir y en la noche llega a ver
las noticias y encuentra que un bebé fue
depositado
basurero estas personas necesitan
nuestra ayuda y nuestra comprensión las
técnicas de repsol así tienen evaluado y
han avanzado impresionantemente es una
de las técnicas donde más medicina
invierten y donde más tecnología e
investigación se hace hoy en día
comparamos el radio de 1922 en un primer
coche de cuatro ruedas yo y pareciera
que con el bluetooth el tener una
consola de radio en nuestros automóviles
parece algo inexplicable eso mismo pasa
con las chicas de infertilidad hace 30
años era un tema muy tabú del mismo no
hablábamos y no sabíamos mucho y hoy en
día esto depende de muchos factores
hablando ligeramente de ciencia los
hombres tenemos aproximadamente 200 a
300 millones de espermatozoides
diariamente y es hasta los 40 años en
donde empezamos a tener diferente forma
diferente calidad y diferente cantidad
en cambio las mujeres tienen una
realidad muchísimo muy diferente las
mujeres cuando están en el nacimiento
tienen aproximadamente 2 millones de
óvulos de esos 2 millones solamente 300
a 400.000 alcanzan la menarca es decir
la fecha de su primera menstruación y
desde los 12 11 años hasta los 32 la
etapa fértil prayer del mes a mes
6 y 22 óvulos de tal manera que una
mujer que alcanza los 32 años puede
tener una reserva perdida entre el 80 y
el 90 por ciento de su función ovárica
les presento a la mujer del siglo 21 una
mujer que le encanta viajar una mujer
que le encanta aportar económicamente
una mujer multifacético una mujer
multitouch una mujer que su pareja lo
apoya pero no es un impedimento y que
tiene un consejo día a día y que a
partir de los 30 años piensa en
concretar un embarazo
esta es una diferencia importante que
afecta de fertilidad hoy la infertilidad
se define desde quién eres desde que
comes y desde cuánto ejercicio haces una
familia de hace 50 60 años era normal
que tuviera entre 8 a 10 hijos y hoy en
día convivimos más con una laptop con
una tablet o con una computadora que con
nuestros propios hermanos son nuestros
padres
el anhelo de tener un hijo es uno de los
más profundos del ser humano pero eso
hace que a veces lo confundamos con un
derecho es un acto tan profundo donde
dos personas se convierten en una para
hacer tres y pareciera que nuestro
pensamiento sobre la infertilidad es
como un wifi del cual los quisiéramos
empapar de cada una de las redes
disponibles y del password que se
necesita para poder tenerlas y además lo
vemos como algo automático como algo
normal como algo que está ahí en el
momento en que lo busquemos y hoy en día
resulta que el password que más
quisiéramos tener es el password de la
infertilidad hoy las parejas se casan
diciendo me voy a cuidar y se cuidan de
algo que no tienen a ciencia cierta por
contado y es por eso tal vez que la
infertilidad es tan dolorosa es como la
lava es lenta pero además implacable y
cuando menos nos damos cuenta tenemos
hasta los hombres un deseo profundo que
nos invade en cada una de las facetas de
nuestra vida
pensando únicamente con el corazón a
veces determinamos que tenemos tantas
ganas de tener un hijo o de concretar un
embarazo y dejamos de lado la parte
racional misma que al tener ciertos
stocks en el camino nos haría
reflexionar algo más objetivo si mi
amiga si la hermana de mi cuñada si mi
colega de trabajo tiene un embarazo y
además tiene un hijo que ya tiene tres
años y está en la piñata de dinosaurio
como las fotos que les pongo aquí yo voy
perdiendo y la infertilidad si alguien
más cercano a mí consigue un embarazo
interpretó como que yo ya voy atrasado a
veces en este tipo de circunstancias hay
que perder para ganar cada uno tiene un
camino diferente y ustedes se
preguntarán por qué puse una foto de una
casa en esta presentación de
infertilidad
en partidos porque soy norteño soy de
monclova y quiero hacer este ejemplo
algo más apto para la infertilidad si yo
les vendía esta casa ustedes me dirían
el que suena está construida me
preguntarían que el grupo de arquitectos
la construyó cuántos cuartos tiene me
preguntaría en cuánta gente cada vez me
preguntaría el precio me preguntarán qué
tal el tamaño del jardín y qué tal el
asador
y por otra parte yo les digo que lo
mismo deberíamos de saber de la
infertilidad hoy no tenemos idea de qué
etapa se involucra no tenemos idea de
cuántas técnicas existen y de qué
factores de riesgo involucra someterte
algo así
la infertilidad es como si pusiéramos
enfrente de nosotros las rutas del metro
de la ciudad de méxico para alguien la
dieta uno puede llevarte a algún destino
que estás esperando pero para alguien la
ruta 22 es la óptima y esto es un
problema que tiene muchos caminos y
pueden tiene muchas soluciones
el problema que les propongo compartir
el día de hoy la desinformación
hoy en día pareciera que las personas
que se intentan por saber más no son
aptas para entrar a nuestra sociedad y
por otra parte los que deciden no saber
quedarse con lo que se les presenta son
bien adaptados en la gente con la que
convivimos es un poco lo que pasa en esa
anécdota de la caverna de platón en
donde esas personas que están
encadenadas podrían parecer las víctimas
en no conocer la realidad que se les
presenta pero por otra parte en esas
personas que parecieran las víctimas hay
una responsabilidad en donde el estar en
esa posición puede ser tan cómodo que no
me someto a conocer más la información
lo que me puedo portar es una decisión
objetiva una decisión madura y una
decisión muy responsable
cuando vimos la película de op y
lloramos muchísimo con esa película y la
sufrimos realmente porque ella le
amarraba las corbatas todos los días y
además no pudo tener un hijo al final
los comentarios que vivimos en esta
sociedad son muy superficiales es muy
común escuchar es que relájate vete de
viaje y te vas a embarazar es que estás
tan obsesionada con un hijo que por eso
no lo logras y las parejas dan una
realidad muchísimo menos simple a la que
estamos viviendo y pensamos que cada uno
de estos comentarios ayuda y lo que
único que hace es ser una puñalada en la
espalda hoy cuatro de cada cinco parejas
considera que su problema no tiene fácil
solución y nosotros debemos de fomentar
esa necesidad de hacerlo en mi círculo
cercano hoy mi mamá tiene que saber más
de infertilidad hoy mis amigos hoy mi
gente con la que convive en el trabajo
tiene que saber y hacer redes de apoyo
porque esto requiere mucha mucha
fortaleza emocional
eso fomenta muchísimo la desinformación
hoy veamos al profesional como un todo
poderoso y entendemos que lo que nos
diga el doctor es suficiente para todo
lo que yo tengo que conocer hoy en día
hay que entender que el algoritmo de la
infertilidad tiene tres bases por un
lado el paciente por otro lado la
técnica y finalmente el 'todopoderoso'
del doctor que así lo vemos hoy en día
cada uno de estos factores tiene ciertas
responsabilidades y ciertos límites y
pareciera que este señor lo que más
tiene que tener es profesionalismo y
sensibilidad
pero cuantos saben realmente las parejas
sobre técnicas de reacción asistida
cuanto consideran saber el 58 por ciento
piensa que tomaron una decisión de
manera informada hay un 42% del 100 que
considera que no se informó lo
suficiente y se precipitó a tomar una
decisión y más del 40 por ciento no
conoce las etapas esto quiere decir que
es lo mismo mentar una moneda al aire o
dividir un auditorio como este en que
esta mitad si conoce lo que puede pasar
por una técnica y estos no lo conocen y
estamos hablando de términos de vida y
términos que nos influyen y nos impactan
directamente pero qué puntos para que
nos demos una idea de la magnitud de
estas técnicas son indispensables
conocer en primer lugar las técnicas y
las tasas que se presentan de éxito hay
que estar seguros que parte de
realidades estamos viendo cuántos
embarazos están concretando y cuántos de
esos embarazos llegan a nacer
y por otra parte recuerden que las
clínicas en este punto softwares y parte
ellos publican los resultados por el mal
tiempo son quienes los interpretan y hoy
les presenta uno de mis mejores amigos y
son los embriones esos embriones cuando
se obtiene el óvulo de la mujer y lo
fecunda mos pueden tener cuatro
diferentes destinos un embrión puede ir
directamente ser transferido pero puede
ser congelado pero les digo que hay un
envión también puede ser desechado
y por otra parte puede ser designado
para la investigación
y que el aspecto biológico es muy
importante que piensen en esta pareja
esta pareja que quiere que lo que le
está pasando no es verdad esta pareja
que no entiende porque si ya tenía
estabilidad social estabilidad económica
tenía todo lo que necesitaba y buscó un
embarazo y no se le dio no entiende
porque eso le pasa a ellos es una pareja
que tiene un boom emocional y que lo
único que piensa es que lo que le tiene
en su vida es un castigo
ustedes y cada uno todos y cada uno
puede hacer esto que está aquí estoy
seguro que en su círculo social viven y
conviven con gente con problemas de
infertilidad porque algo muy común y
todos pueden hacer esos oídos y esas
palabras para la gente que quiere
compartir su problema cuatro de cada
diez personas comparte su problema con
alguien de su confianza y porque
nosotros no podemos hacer algo como
sociedad para esas personas que
requieren de nuestra ayuda que propongo
una solución integral una solución que
involucre el aspecto social el aspecto
biológico y el aspecto emocional y que
no sea más una enfermedad de tabú una
enfermedad del día a día que está en
boca de todos
en qué momento en ese primer momento
donde la pareja no entiende lo que le
pasa en ese segundo momento donde tengo
que tener una actitud activa pero
también flexible y una vez teniendo todo
en la mano decido qué es lo que tengo
que hacer bajo la luz de la ética y la
moral y doy ese siguiente paso
el día de hoy el principal motivo de
esta plática es que despertemos una
cultura dormida una cultura que hace
tiempo que vemos como rara y en la
cultura de la opción hoy en día el 63.3
por ciento de las parejas no piensan en
la adopción más sin embargo el 90 por
ciento y más considera que es igual de
importante tener un embarazo biológico a
un embarazo adoptivo hoy en día las
principales causas de por qué las
parejas no adoptan es por el tiempo que
les toma el proceso de adopción y hay
alguien que lo ve como un embarazo más
largo y nada más vean las caras de esas
personas donde está un sentimiento de
cariño de felicidad de entrega y les
digo algo la felicidad está en la
adopción hoy en día cualquier tipo de
maternidad es adoptiva incluso aunque
seas fértil incluso que puedas tener un
hijo si así lo decides tienes que
decidir adoptiva mente tener un bebé y
es por eso que hoy en día hay muchos
bebés que no están en este mundo
son mis conclusiones es tiempo de
cambiar el paradigma de la infertilidad
por una prevención y manejo de la misma
hoy no más no hablar de la infertilidad
hoy no más dejarla como atrás de la
montaña y no como una realidad hoy la
solución está en todos nosotros nuestra
generación merece estar empoderada en
cada uno de estos términos y nosotros
tenemos el conocimiento y compartirlo es
poder para tomar decisiones importantes
en cada uno de los momentos
trascendentales de nuestras vidas la
sociedad quiere prolongar la fertilidad
pero la fisiología y lo que somos
siempre será lo mismo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]